GROUPTHINK.
>> Sean: GREAT SHOW.
WHILE COME TO "HANNITY."
FOX NEWS ALERT.
BREAKING MOMENTS AGO, GEORGIA
CONGRESSMAN DOUG COLLINS HAS
RELEASED EIGHT CLOSED-DOOR
HEARING TRANSCRIPTS FROM HIS
COMMITTEE'S INVESTIGATIONS INTO
THE FBI AND OBAMA DOJ.
WE KNOW, HERE IT COMES, THIS IS
WHAT I'VE BEEN TELLING YOU,
CASCADING DOWN THE AVALANCHE, WE
HAVE SCORES OF NEW TRANSCRIPTS
FROM LORETTA LYNCH.
EITHER SHE OR COMEY ARE LYING.
ANDREW MCCABE, JAMES RYBICKI,
MANY OTHER HIGH-RANKING
OFFICIALS.
BASED ON THESE NEWLY RELEASED
DOCUMENTS, WE CAN NOW CONFIRM
ONE MAJOR PIECE OF INFORMATION.
FORMER ATTORNEY GENERAL UNDER
BARACK OBAMA, THAT'S RIGHT,
LYNCH, THROUGH JAMES COMEY RIGHT
UNDER THE BOSS AND TOLD CONGRESS
SHE NEVER ASKED THE
EMBATTLED FBI DIRECTOR TO REFERT
EMBATTLED FBI DIRECTOR TO REFERO
THE CLINTON CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION AS "A MATTER."
COMEY SAID JUST THE OPPOSITE.
ONE OF THEM IS LYING.
WHO LIED TO CONGRESS?
WHO COMMITTED THE CRIME UNDER
OATH?
IT WOULD BE A SERIOUS VIOLATION.
OH, YEAH, IT WAS IMPORTANT ON
THE TRUMP SITE.
NOW THE MAINSTREAM HATE-TRUMP
MEDIA MOB DO THEIR JOB ON THIS S
MEDIA MOB DO THEIR JOB ON THIS D
MEDIA MOB DO THEIR JOB ON THIS .
WHERE COMEY THROUGH THIS
INFORMATION, EACH LINE OF EVERY
TRANSCRIPT, WE HAVE FULL
ANALYSIS.
GREGG JARRETT, SARA CARTER, SO
MUCH MORE.
ALSO BREAKING, THE PRESIDENT
WRAPPED UP A RAUCOUS RALLY IN
PENNSYLVANIA, DRAWING AWAY
BIGGER CROWD THAN ANY OF HIS
DEMOCRATIC CHALLENGERS,
INCLUDING SLEEPY CREEPY CRAZY
UNCLE JOE, NOW COMING UP OR
GOING TO SHOW YOU THE HIGHLIGHTS
FROM
TONIGHT'S SPEECH.
FIRST WE HAVE MORE THAN BREAKING
NEWS OUT OF THE DEEP STATE.
WERE GOING TO GO SLOW TONIGHT.
WILL MAKE SURE WE GET IT ALL IN.
I WANT TO SET THE STAGE.
TONIGHT IS JUST THE BEGINNING OF
WHAT IS COMING EVERY DAY, WEEK,
MONTH AHEAD, THERE'S A TOWN OF
IT.
AN AVALANCHE OF NEW INFORMATION,
NEW DOCUMENTS.
THEY WILL ALL REVEAL A SHOCKING
LEVEL OF CORRUPTION, BIAS,
LAWLESSNESS AT THE HIGHEST
LEVELS OF THE DEEP STATE.
IT'S ALL ABOUT TO BE REVEALED.
AT THIS HOUR, YOUR FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS IN POSSESSION OF
TRANSCRIPTS FROM 2016 FEATURING
SECRETLY RECORDED CONVERSATIONS
BETWEEN FBI INFORMANTS AND
ONE-TIME TRUMP CAMPAIGN AIDE
GEORGE PAPADOPOULOS.
ACCORDING TO THOSE WHO HAVE SEEN
THESE TRANSCRIPTS, ITS CONTENTS
ARE CHOCK-FULL OF CLEAR
IRREFUTABLE, INCONTROVERTIBLE,
EXCULPATORY EVIDENCE PROVING
TRUMP-RUSSIA COLLUSION WAS
ALWAYS A HOAX FROM THE GET-GO.
THIS INCLUDES FORMER CONGRESSMAN
TREY GOWDY WHO IS NOW CALLING
THESE DOCUMENTS "GAME CHANGING."
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> IF THE BUREAU IS GOING TO
SEND AN INFORMANT, THE INFORMANT
IS GOING TO BE WIRED.
IF THE BUREAU'S MONITORING
TELEPHONE CALLS, THERE'S GOING
TO BE A TRANSCRIPT.
SOME OF US HAVE BEEN FORTUNATE
ENOUGH TO KNOW WHETHER THOSE
TRANSCRIPTS EXIST BUT THEY
HAVEN'T BEEN MADE PUBLIC AND I
THINK ONE IN PARTICULAR IS GOING
-- IT HAS THE POTENTIAL TO
ACTUALLY PERSUADE PEOPLE.
VERY LITTLE ON THE STRUCTURE
PROBE I'M AFRAID IS GOING TO
PERSUADE PEOPLE WHO HATE TRUMP
OR WHO LOVE TRUMP.
BUT THERE IS SOME INFORMATION IN
THESE TRANSCRIPTS THAT I THINK
HAS THE POTENTIAL TO BE A
GAME CHANGER IF IT'S EVER MADE
PUBLIC.
>> Sean: THIS MATERIAL MUST BE
MADE AVAILABLE.
WHERE IS JERRY NADLER?
ADAM SCHIFF, THE BIGGEST LIAR IN
CONGRESS.
BECAUSE IF COMEY -- THE HIGHEST
LEVEL OFFICIALS, NOT
RANK-AND-FILE.
WE MAKE THE DISTINCTION.
I'M AN FBI PIN IN AN CIA PIN ON.
THE 99% WHO PROTECT US EVERY DAY
BUT THOSE IN THE FBI AND THE CIA
IN THE UPPER ECHELON, THE INTEL
COMMUNITY, THEY ARE WITHHOLDING
EXCULPATORY EVIDENCE, LET ME
TELL YOU THIS IS BIGGER THAN WE
EVER THOUGHT 30 MEANS THE OF
PREMEDITATED FRAUD, CONSPIRACY
AGAINST THE FISA COURT, THAT
MEANS THERE WAS A REAL ATTEMPT
TO STEAL A PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION
WITH RUSSIAN LIES PAID FOR BY
HILLARY AND AN EFFORT WHEN THEY
LOST, TO UNSEAT A DULY ELECTED
PRESIDENT OF YOU, THE PEOPLE.
MUCH WORSE THAN WE EVER KNEW.
KEEP IN MIND PAPADOPOULOS, HE
WAS JUST ONE OF SEVERAL TRUMP
CAMPAIGN MEMBERS WHO IN FACT
WERE BEING SURVEILLED BY COMEY'S
FBI.
THIS TRANSCRIPT IS JUST ONE OF
SEVERAL.
WE HAVE TOLD HER THERE'S FIVE.
INFORMATION WILL SOON BE
REVEALED.
WE ARE ALSO EXPECTING THE
DECLASSIFIED FISA APPLICATION
AGAINST CARTER PAGE.
THAT SHOULD REVEAL HOW COMEY AND
OTHERS TOTALLY, COMPLETELY
RELIED ON THE PHONY CLINTON
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION DOSSIER THAT WAS
PASSED OFF AS VERIFIED MATERIAL
AND WE NOW KNOW THEY WERE WARNED
REPEATEDLY THAT IT WAS NOT.
THIS WEEKEND, FORMER CONGRESSMAN
GOWDY HAD THIS TO SAY ABOUT THE
DEEP STATES LOVE AFFAIR WITH
CHRISTOPHER STEELE'S
UNVERIFIABLE -- HE DOESN'T STAND
BY IT -- DIRTY DOSSIER.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE CAN CALL IT A DOSSIER.
IT SOUNDS OFFICIAL.
IT'S REALLY SOMETHING THE
"NATIONAL ENQUIRER" WOULD BLUSH
IF THEY PRINTED.
WE KNOW IT WAS USED FOUR TIMES
BY THE UNITED STATES GOVERNMENT.
WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
IS WHETHER OR NOT IT WAS YOU TO
FIFTH IN THE INTELLIGENCE
ASSESSMENT.
YOU HAVE BRENNAN, CLAPPER,
COMEY, ALL THREE WHO KNOW FULL
WELL WHETHER OR NOT IT WAS USED
IN THE INTELLIGENCE ASSESSMENT,
BUT THEY ARE GIVING YOU
DIFFERENT VERSIONS.
>> Sean: IF JUSTICE IS SERVED,
WILL ALL HAVE ACCESS TO THE SAME
MATERIAL TREY GOWDY REVIEWED AS
A SITTING MEMBER OF CONGRESS.
TONIGHT GOOD NEWS ACCORDING TO
THE FREEDOM CAUCUS CHAIRMAN MARK
MEADOWS, OF NORTH CAROLINA.
HE IS TALKING ABOUT DOCUMENT
RELEASES THAT ARE JUST AROUND
THE CORNER, AS WE'VE BEEN
TELLING YOU.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I THINK THE DELAYS OVER AND I
THINK THE PRESIDENT IS SERIOUS.
I HAVE SPOKEN TO HIM RECENTLY
AND I THINK DECLASSIFICATION IS
RIGHT AROUND THE CORNER, AND
HOPEFULLY THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
WILL BE ABLE TO JUDGE IT
THEMSELVES.
>> Sean: WHILE WE LOOK FORWARD
TO THE RELEASE OF THE FISA
APPLICATION, THE PAPADOPOULOS
TRANSCRIPT, ONE FORMER FBI AGENT
WITH THE HELP OF JUDICIAL WATCH
IS NOW REQUESTING A TROVE OF
DOCUMENTS RELATED TO
ANDREW MCCABE, OPERATION MIDYEAR
EXAM.
THAT IS THE ONE AGAINST HILLARY.
THE SERVER AND THE INTENT WAS TO
DESTROY THE SUBPOENAED EMAILS.
33,000 OF THEM.
AS YOU KNOW, McCABE WAS COMEY
SECOND IN COMMAND OF THE FBI
UNTIL HE WAS FIRED.
NOW THERE IS A CRIMINAL REFERRAL
FOR "REPEATED LYING."
ACCORDING TO A BRAND-NEW REPORT
OUT FROM SARA CARTER THIS
EVENING, A RETIRED FBI AGENT
ISSUED A FOIA REQUEST FOR EMAILS
RELATED TO McCABE'S WIFE AND
THE CLINTONS.
REMEMBER THE CASE?
JOE McCABE HAD DEEP TIES TO
CLINTON.
WATCH THE 2015 STATE SENATE
CAMPAIGN AT THE BEHEST OF THE
VIRGINIA GOVERNOR, CLINTON
HACKED TERRY McAULIFFE.
AND THE CAMPAIGN ACCEPTED NEARLY
HALF A MILLION DOLLARS FROM
McAULIFFE'S POLITICAL ACTION
COMMITTEE AND ANOTHER 292,000
FROM A SECOND DEMOCRATIC PACK.
LET ME PUT THIS IN PERSPECTIVE.
THAT'S AN OBSCENE, UNPRECEDENTED
AMOUNT OF MONEY FOR A LITTLE
STATE SENATE CAMPAIGN.
FRANKLY, AN OBSCENE AMOUNT OF
MONEY FOR ANY SUCH RACE.
CLEARLY THIS DOES REPRESENT YET
ANOTHER CALM SLICKED OF INTEREST
AT THE HIGHEST LEVELS OF THE FBI
AT THE HIGHEST LEVELS OF THE FBW
AT THE HIGHEST LEVELS OF THE FBH
CLEARLY HAD THEIR
FAVORITE CANDIDATE IN 2016 AND
WE ALL KNOW IT WAS NOT
DONALD TRUMP.
THAT'S WHY THERE WAS AN
EXONERATION BEFORE AN
INVESTIGATION.
THAT'S WHY IT'S IRREFUTABLE,
INCONTROVERTIBLE EVIDENCE.
YOU BROKE THE LAW, VIOLATED THE
ESPIONAGE ACT AND HAD THE INTENT
OF DESTROYING THE EVIDENCE WHEN
SHE DELETED 33,000 SUBPOENAED
EMAILS, BLEACHED BIT THE HARD
DRIVE, HAD IN A BUS THE DEVICE
AND YANKED OUT THE SIM CARD.
THE CHOSEN ONE, HILLARY CLINTON,
WAS GIVEN THE FREE PASS AFTER
SHE DID ALL OF THIS.
THERE WAS CLASSIFIED, TOP-SECRET
MATERIAL.
THEN THE OBSTRUCTION.
EVERYTHING THAT I NOW TOLD YOU.
FREE PASS FOR OBVIOUS CRIMES
WHILE THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES IS FORCED TO
ENDURE A NEARLY THREE YEAR
WITCH HUNT.
BASED ENTIRELY ON A HOAX THAT
THEY KNEW OF FROM THE GET-GO.
I WANT TO GET BACK TO MY
MONOLOGUE IN A MINUTE BY JOINING
US NOW WITH MCCABE'S CONFLICT OF
INTEREST, FOX NEWS INVESTIGATIVE
REPORTER SARA CARTER.
YOU HAVE BEEN WORKING ON THE
STORY FOR QUITE SOME TIME.
IT IS ABOUT TO BE RELEASED.
>> YES, FORMER SUPERVISORY
SPECIAL AGENT JEFFREY DANEK HAS
BEEN FIGHTING FOR OVER TWO YEARS
WITH JUDICIAL WATCH TO GET THE
TEXT MESSAGES OF FORMER DEPUTY
DIRECTOR AND HER McCABE.
APPARENTLY IT'S A TREASURE
TROVE.
IT'S NOT ONLY GOING TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS REGARDING HIS WIFE AND
THOSE ISSUES BUT APPARENTLY
THERE'S A LOT MORE INFORMATION
CONTAINED IN THESE TEXT MESSAGES
AND EMAILS THAT THE FBI DOES NOT
WANT RELEASE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE HAS
BEEN FIGHTING JUDICIAL WATCH ON
THIS IN THE COURTS AND JUDICIAL
WATCH FILED A MOTION LAST WEEK
AGAINST THE DOJ TO RELEASE THE
DOCUMENTS.
JUDICIAL WATCH IS EXPECTING THE
DOJ TO TURN THOSE DOCUMENTS OVER
AND AS YOU STATED EARLIER, SEAN,
THERE IS NOW THE OFFICIAL
TRANSCRIPTS RIGHT HERE THAT HAVE
BEEN RELEASED BY REPRESENTATIVE
COLLINS.
WE ARE SCOURING THROUGH THEM,
JUST AS YOU ARE.
I THINK SOME OF THE MOST
INTERESTING THINGS THAT I'VE
DISCOVERED RELATE TO TRICIA
ANDERSON, SHE WAS AN FBI
NATIONAL SECURITY LAWYER, AND
SHE WAS WORKING DIRECTLY WITH
JAMES BAKER AS WELL AS LISA
PAGE.
IN HER TRANSCRIPT IN THE BACK
AND FORTH WITH THE QUESTIONERS,
SHE TALKS ABOUT BRUCE OHR AND
THE 302s.
SHE TALKS ABOUT THE FACT THAT
SHE BASICALLY SIGNED OFF ON THE
FIRST FISA WARRANT ON CARTER
PAGE.
AS YOU STATED EARLIER, CARTER
PAGE RIGHT NOW, THERE ARE
TRANSCRIPTS EXPECTED TO BE
RELEASED OF HIS CONVERSATIONS AS
WELL WITH STEFAN HALPER.
SIMILAR TO GEORGE PAPADOPOULOS.
WHO WAS BEING PROBED BY STEFAN
HALPER WHO WAS A FORMER BRITISH
PROFESSOR WHO WAS GATHERING
INFORMATION FOR THE FBI AND
SPYING ON THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
THE MOST INTERESTING FACT I
THINK, AND I WILL LEAVE YOU WITH
THIS, SEAN, IS THAT TRICIA
ANDERSON BASICALLY TRIES TO
DOWNPLAY BRUCE OHR'S INVOLVEMENT
WHEN THEY QUESTION ABOUT BEING
THE BACK CHANNEL FOR CHRISTOPHER
STEELE AFTER THE FBI FIRED HIM.
THEY QUESTION HER OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
IF THE FBI ACTUALLY HAD ENOUGH
EVIDENCE, ENOUGH EVIDENCE TO GO
AFTER A FISA WITH WHAT THEY
FOUND IN THE DOSSIER.
TRICIA ANDERSON REFUSES TO
ANSWER ON MULTIPLE OCCASIONS.
IT'S GOING TO BE VERY
INTERESTING TO SEE WHAT COMES
OUT NEXT.
IT'S GOING TO BE VERY
INTERESTING TO SEE WHAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, WILLIAM
BARR, ATTORNEY GENERAL WILLIAM
BARR, WILL HAVE AS FAR AS
INFORMATION ON, YOU KNOW, ON THE
INVESTIGATION AND HOW IT
COINCIDES WITH THESE
TRANSCRIPTS.
I THINK PEOPLE HAVE A LOT OF
ANSWERING TO DO.
>> Sean: A LOT OF SPYING.
HE FORGOT THE BOND MOVIE BLONDE
BOMBSHELL WITH PAPADOPOULOS.
SAM CLOVIS, PAPADOPOULOS, CARTER
PAGE, FISA WARRANT.
JAMES COMEY.
THAT WASN'T SPYING.
SIGNED OFF ON THE FIRST FISA
APPLICATION IN OCTOBER 2016.
VERIFYING ITS TRUE AND ACCURATE
BUT TOLD FROM LATER KNOW, IT'S
UNVERIFIED.
AND NOW LORETTA LYNCH
CONTRADICTING THE TESTIMONY.
GREAT JOB.
THANK YOU.
ALSO BREAKING, WE DID LEARN THAT
THE MUELLER INVESTIGATORS WERE
GIVEN PERMISSION BY THE BRITISH
GOVERNMENT TO INTERVIEW THE
DIRTY DOSSIERS AUTHOR,
CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
YES, THAT CHRISTOPHER STEELE,
THE GUY WHO DOES NOT STAND
BEHIND HIS OWN DOSSIER, THE
CHRISTOPHER STEELE IN AN
INTERROGATORY UNDER THE THREAT
OF PERJURY SAYS I DON'T KNOW IF
ANY OF THIS IS TRUE.
THE SAME STEELE THAT WAS FIRED
BY THE FBI FOR LYING AND
LEAKING, THE SAME STEELE WHO WAS
BACK CHANNELING WE KNOW NOW
INFORMATION TO MUELLER'S
INVESTIGATORS AFTER BEING FIRED
THROUGH BRUCE OHR.
OF COURSE, DID YOU GET THIS TO
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL?
WHY WOULD YOU TRUST A LIAR AND
LEAGUER?
MUELLER CONCLUDED THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN DID NOT COLLUDE IN ANY
WAY WITH THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT.
FOUR SEPARATE INVESTIGATIONS.
WE CAN NOW DEDUCE, STEELE'S
SO-CALLED INTEL, HE DOESN'T
STAND BY IT.
HE THINKS IT'S B.S., AND IT
ALWAYS WAS.
IT WAS JAMES COMEY, HIS
HIGH-RANKING DEPUTIES, THAT
SWORE THAT THE CONTENTS WERE
TRUE AND ACCURATE AND THE WORD
VERIFIED APPEARS AT THE VERY TOP
OF THE FISA REQUEST APPLICATION.
THAT WAS IN TECH CARTER PAGE TO
GET THINGS TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND
TRANSITION AND ALL THINGS AS
PRESIDENT.
THIS IS WHY I'VE BEEN CALLING IT
THE BIGGEST ABUSE OF POWER,
CORRUPTION SCANDAL IN OUR
HISTORY.
JUST TO RECAP: THE DEATH DEPUTY
FBI DIRECTOR ANDREW MCCABE,
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION,
REFERRAL, FIRED FOR LYING.
LEAD INVESTIGATOR, PETER STRZOK,
PAGE, FIRED.
POLITICAL BIAS.
LISA PAGE, RESIGNING.
GENERAL COUNSEL BAKER RESIGNING,
REPORTEDLY FACING A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION FOR LINKING.
COMEY'S CHIEF OF STAFF, JAMES
RYBICKI, ALSO 25 IN TOTAL
BETWEEN THE STATE DEPARTMENT AND
FBI FIRED, LEAVING IN DISGRACE
WERE DEMOTED.
BRUCE OHR WAS ONCE THE FOURTH
HIGHEST RANKING MEMBER AT THE
DOJ.
LET'S NOT FORGET JAMES COMEY
HIMSELF WAS FIRED FOR
MISHANDLING THE CLINTON
INVESTIGATION.
THAT IS COMEY'S LEGACY.
TURMOIL, BIAS, CORRUPTION AT THE
HIGHEST LEVELS OF WHAT IS RIGHT
THERE THE SINGLE GREATEST
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY IN THE
ENTIRE WORLD TAINTING THE 99% OF
PEOPLE THAT RISKED THEIR LIVES
FOR US.
IF YOU LISTEN TO MR. COMEY, WHO
THINKS HE'S SMARTER THAN US, HE
THINKS HE'S A SUPER PATRIOT, HE
KNEW BETTER THAN THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
OH, HE COULD DO NO WRONG
WHATSOEVER.
EVERYONE ELSE IS BAD.
EVERYONE ELSE IS EVIL.
NATURALLY, COMEY ALL TOO HAPPY
TO PARROT DEMOCRATIC TALKING
POINTS ABOUT ATTORNEY GENERAL
BARR, WRITING ON TWITTER "THE AG
SHOULD STOP SLIMING HIS OWN
DEPARTMENT.
IF THERE ARE BAD FACTS, SHOW US.
OR SEARCH FOR THEM
PROFESSIONALLY AND TELL US WE
FOUND.
AG MUST ACT LIKE THE LEADER OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, AN
ORGANIZATION BASED ON TRUTH.
DONALD TRUMP HAS ENOUGH
SPOKESPEOPLE."
JIM, I SUGGEST A MIRROR.
TAKE A LOOK.
ACCORDING TO
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL," BARR
IS FIGHTING BACK AND REMINDING
COMEY HE IS FIGHTING FOR THE
PRESIDENCY, WHICH IS HIS
RIGHTFUL DUTY IN THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH.
PERHAPS COMEY COULD USE A
REFRESHER COURSE ON HOW CHECKS
AND BALANCES WORK.
BUT REALLY, JAMES COMEY?
SEARCH FOR THEM PROFESSIONALLY?
YOU ARE THE SAME JAMES COMEY
THAT ALLOWED LORETTA LYNCH TO
DICTATE ACCORDING TO YOUR
TESTIMONY THE TERMS OF THE
INVESTIGATION INTO
HILLARY CLINTON WHEN YOU MADE NO
REAL ATTEMPT TO VERIFY THAT
PHONY CLINTON OFTEN PAID FOR
DOSSIER.
YOU KNEW AHEAD OF TIME, YOU WERE
TOLD BY BRUCE OHR AHEAD OF TIME.
YOU KNEW FROM THE
STATE DEPARTMENT TEN DAYS
EARLIER AND YOU STILL DID IT.
USING THAT AS THE BASIS,
UNVERIFIED RUSSIAN DOSSIER PAID
FOR BY CLINTON.
OF COURSE YOU DIDN'T TELL THE
COURT CLINTON BOUGHT AND PAID
FOR THIS GARBAGE.
A FISA WARRANT USED TO SPY ON
THE MEMBER OF THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
SO YOU COULD SPY ON THE WHOLE
CAMPAIGN.
ALL YOU DON'T CALL SIGNING A
FISA APPLICATION SPYING.
IT IS BY DEFINITION SPYING.
BECAUSE NOW YOU ARE BUGGING
EVERY SINGLE ASPECT OF CARTER
PAGE AND GETTING A SNEAK PEEK
INTO ALL THINGS THE WORLD TRUMP.
WHEN YOU LEAK CONFIDENTIAL NOTES
ON PRIVATE CONVERSATIONS, YOU
HAD WITH THE PRESIDENT,
DISPARATE SPECIAL COUNSEL
INVESTIGATION.
YEAH, IT'S THAT PROFESSIONALLY
THE SEARCH FOR TRUTH AND
JUSTICE?
AT THE FBI, JIMBO?
JIM COMEY KNOWS HE'S IN DEEP
TROUBLE TONIGHT.
THE PROBLEM WITH COMEY'S I GAVE
HIM THIS MORNING ALONG TIME AGO
BEFORE THE DOLBY BULK OF HIS
CAME OUT.
YOU SHOULD GET OFF TWITTER, STOP
WRITING DUMB BOOKS, STAY AWAY
FROM FAKE NEW CNN AND YOU DO
HAVE THE RIGHT TO REMAIN SILENT.
I KEEP SUGGESTING YOU USE IT.
BECAUSE THE TRUTH IS GOING TO BE
REVEALED IN MOMENTS AGO DURING A
MASSIVE RALLY IN PENNSYLVANIA,
THE PRESIDENT HAD THIS TO SAY
ABOUT THE DISGUSTING DEEP STATE
CORRUPTION THAT TOOK PLACE UNDER
JIM COMEY'S WATCH UNDER THE
BIDEN-OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
THE WHOLE THING WAS UNDER THEIR
WATCH.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> President Trump: THIS PHONY
WITCH HUNT THAT WE ALL WENT
THROUGH TOGETHER IS A DISGRACE.
NOW THEY ARE ALL BLAMING EACH
OTHER.
DID YOU SEE?
THEY ARE ALL TURNING ON EACH
OTHER.
ISN'T THAT PRETTY TO WATCH?
IT'S HIS FAULT.
NO, IT'S HIS FAULT.
NO, WE CAUGHT THEM.
THEY WERE SPYING.
THEY WERE SPYING ON OUR
CAMPAIGN.
I TELL YOU WHAT.
IF THAT EVER HAPPENED TO THE
OTHER SIDE, THIS THING WOULD'VE
BEEN OVER TWO YEARS AGO.
YOU KNOW, IT WOULD'VE BEEN
TREASON.
THEY WOULD'VE CALLED IT TREASON.
THAT'S WHAT IT IS.